the threat of an economic downturn is
shaking up consumers and small business
owners a recent survey taken by goldman
sachs found 93 percent 93 percent of
small businesses fear a recession and 89
are affected by inflation supply chain
issues and workforce challenges the
giant investment bank opens its ten
thousand small business summit today in
washington it includes a lobbying effort
to get lawmakers attention with slogans
like small business big voice like that
goldman sachs ceo and chairman david
solomon joins us first on cbs mornings
good morning to you david salmons good
to see you
good morning gail how are you this
morning
i'm okay for a tuesday morning we're
going to talk about the summit in just a
second but i want to talk about the
recession first are you preparing for a
recession are you worried about a
recession
well um as so many americans are gail
i'm concerned about the possibility of a
recession it's not clear it's not baked
in the cake that there's going to be a
recession but there's no question given
the inflation that we have in our
economy
you're seeing a tightening of economic
conditions and there is certainly a
chance that that can lead to a recession
and so
we're advising our clients to be
cautious right now it's a period of
uncertainty it's a difficult period for
many uh and we're saying that it's time
to be cautious but we're not sure it's
hard to predict whether or not there'll
be a recession and some of that will
depend on some of the policy actions
from here forward
but on your earnings call yesterday did
you say we're not going to do any hiring
right now that we're going to take some
measures ourselves within goldman sachs
well what we said on our earnings call
yesterday gail is that we're going to
slow the pace of our hiring we've
actually grown the firm quite
extensively over the last few years and
we still have programs in certain areas
we're investing where we're going to
continue to hire but the pace of the
hiring is going to slow
and so we commented on the fact that
we're reviewing the pace of hiring and
also thinking about certain areas um
where we may slow the pace of investment
given our concern about the potential
for a slower economic environment
hey mr solomon uh it's tony decopal here
uh good morning to you we said in the
introduction uh that goldman sachs in
his own survey there with small business
owners that 93 of small business owners
are concerned about a recession so as
you're mixing with with those small
business owners there in d.c what are
you advising them what are you telling
them and also what are you hearing from
them about their worries
well good morning tony and i i
appreciate that and it is it's true that
our survey did say that 93 of small
business owners are concerned about a
recession but the survey also said that
over 61 of them are excited about the
prospects of their business going
forward and i would just say while
people are concerned this is a group of
very entrepreneurial and minded people
who are really driving economic growth
in america and excited about the
prospects that they have and so one of
the things
i would say in my discussions with them
is they believe in the resiliency of the
american economy and they're optimistic
but they're concerned inflation is
obviously concerning and like everyone
else in america right now they're
concerned and watching but at the same
time really trying to focus on investing
and growing their businesses
and i'm giving them that same kind of
advice i think it's a time to be
cautious but you also have to take a
long-term view we will get through this
um and it's important to take the long
view and invest in your business and try
to grow your business even in
challenging times but maybe with a
little bit more caution right now
david it's vlad i want to switch gears
for a moment and talk about uh the
announcement by goldman sachs that the
company will cover travel expenses for
people who need an abortion
how and why did the company make that
decision
well my number one priority is to really
worry about the health and the
well-being of our employees and so after
the supreme court decision we looked at
our medical policies and we've decided
to make sure that if anyone needs any
medical treatment of any kind and they
can't find it locally that we'll support
them to make sure they're taken care of
because the health and well-being of our
employees has always been my number one
priority
hey david the small business summit is
meeting with hundreds of lawmakers this
week what is your message what is your
message to them
well i think there's there's a lot that
we can do to continue to support small
businesses small businesses are such a
vital part of economic activity here in
this country gail they support so much
of the job growth and job creation in
this country i think there are things
that we can do to reignite the small
business administration and provide
support to access credit for small
businesses to also find ways to support
the growth and investment in small
businesses and so we're here to let
those small businesses express directly
to their legislators how they can be
supported to help drive economic growth
across the country
david solomon thank you so much for your
time listen i know you're a man of many
talents when you're not when you're not
a ceo one of the top in the country
you're also a dj i love your dj name
dj diesel
diesel
there you go dj diesel because you've
got an upcoming performance in
lollapalooza i'm wondering did anybody
ever tell you you know david that's not
really a good look for a ceo of your
stature and this company anybody ever
try to discourage you because you have a
great time at this table
i um i i have a hobby and i enjoy the
hobby and um it helps me connect and
relate to what's going on culturally and
so i enjoy it and i'm going to do it
periodically and all the all the fees
that i'm paid to do at gail all go to
charity particularly with a focus on
supporting mental health which is a big
issue right now across the united states
and so i appreciate the opportunity i
have to pursue my hobby in my free time
and let's say you're very good at your
hobby mr solomon we thank you so much
for your time see you later on